hey youtubers is charlie this is gonna
be my breakdown of the Warcraft footage
that they showed a comic-con just like a
lot of the other trailers they're taking
this down hardcore so I'm gonna to get a
little creative with the way that I show
footage but if you played the game
you've seen the cutscenes you have kind
of an idea they take a really primitive
version of what the CG is going to look
like in this film just to be clear the
CG in this movie will be a billion times
better than the CG in Warcraft cutscenes
but blizzard does spend millions and
millions of dollars making it look
really amazing so it seems like the
events in this film take place between
like one of the first big wars between
orcs in the humans the Oryx land is
dying so they want to go through the
Dark Portal to invade Azeroth just to
make them more sympathetic the version
of Outland that we see in this movie is
much closer to what we saw during
burning crusade if you've been playing
warlords of Draenor there's a lot of
time travel that that gets into where
outland hasn't gotten to that point yet
but you're just working down the cast
list you'll probably recognize at least
some of these names so there's loads are
played by Travis Fimmel he's known as
the Lion of Azeroth he's the commander
of the human army King Rin is played by
Dominic Cooper who you probably
recognize his Howard Stark from agent
Carter from the Iron Man movies lady
Toria is his wife she's the queen of
Stormwind Ben Foster is playing medieval
his apprentice CAD guards being played
by Ben Shatner dorrough tan who's the
leader of the orcish horde is being
played by Tony kebbel he's actually
Doctor Doom in the Fantastic Four movie
too all grim is being played by Robert
Kazinsky he was the one they were
parading around at comic-con they even
brought a full scale model of his
character like he was he was standing up
here next to it corona is a half human
half orc slave she's being played by
paula patton and gould on is being
played by daniel wu he's the actual
person that opens the dark portal into
Azeroth the only other really big
character is black and being played by
clancy brown which and everyone gets
really excited about Clancy Brown is
probably like one of the most
recognizable voices ever in addition to
the footage being shown off Robert
Kazinsky actually told a really funny
story about how he lost one of his
relationships to a warcraft addiction
and it should also be noted that henry
cavill way back when man is still came
out admitted during the press tour that
he missed the call when Zack Snyder was
like congratulations you know you're
gonna be the next Superman he missed
that call because he was in a raid with
his guild so Superman is
also a huge Warcraft addict most of the
comic con footage just focused on the
orc side of the story explaining why it
was they wanted to invade Azeroth
because they needed to not because they
wanted to if you haven't played the
warcraft game outland is just the place
that orc scum from and it is slowly
dying the movie picks up as the orcs are
seeking their last resort finding a new
home and they know about Azeroth the
twist is is that in order to open the
portal to Azeroth they have to extract
souls from thousands and thousands of
slaves they call them the fuel for the
fell as an fel that's basically like a
type of magic that derives from demon
blood the orc army travels through the
portal and then we meet the humans when
we get to the other side and they start
gearing up for this really big massive
fight just like a lot of war movies they
tease you know that that not every one
of the orcs and not every one of the
humans believes that the other side is
evil really I think the highlight of the
footage they showed off was them
traveling through the Dark Portal if
anybody ever played Warcraft to like the
really really old-school warcraft to
that was one of the coolest things ever
obviously you know world of warcraft
really took that and ran with it i think
the first expansion that allowed you to
travel through to outland was either
2005 or 2006 a writ original warcraft
was like 2,000 for it was like you know
about every two years they released an
expansion Wow cutscenes I've gotten
pretty good in the last couple of years
especially with the last couple of
expansions but the CG in this movie will
melt your brain they were actually they
were doing this really special thing at
comic-con just as a way to do something
fun they did a 360 degree video that
allowed you to fly over stormwind just
imagine stormwind from the game on acid
like it was just like taken to the nth
degree of detail they didn't say when
they're going to release an official
trailer and then they keep taking down
all the rips so I'd advise you guys
against trying to post this just just in
case you want to get super band but the
director Duncan Jones said that they
allotted extra time like a whole extra
year the movie was going to come out
this summer they pushed it to next
summer just so they have an extra year
to work on special effects just to
fine-tune the film itself that's
actually a pretty rare thing because
this is like like a billion dollar
endeavor for legendary so for them to
like put that off says a lot about how
much they care about the film just
because all this lure flows from the
game I know everyone's asking like you
know what's
to happen with the sequel movie in the
movies after that I mean obviously yeah
they're going to turn this into a
franchise so we'll see Warcraft to
warcraft 3 you know however long that
continue to be successful because this
is legendary entertainment that's behind
this movie and Blizzard are the people
behind the game I'm not expecting a
whole lot of crossover but do expect
some really special tions and expect
some really cool stuff to happen at
blizzcon next year even though the two
companies they're going to do a lot of
stuff together they'll do a lot of
cross-promotion they want the tens of
millions of people that have played the
game to enjoy the movie and vice versa
like they want the people that go see
the movie to check the game out so let
me know what you guys think I've you
know just based on statistics at least
ninety percent of you have probably
played Warcraft at some time in your
life whether it be the MMO or the
classic games it's a lot of fun I feel
like you can go back and play the old
games and they still hold up there's
still a ton of fun Blizzard is getting
ready to shut down starcraft like
they're releasing the final expansion
the legacy of the void and that will be
it I'll be interested to see how long we
go before someone tries to make a
starcraft movie maybe that's what
legendary I'll do next let me know would
you like to see them you know just based
on what you've seen about this movie try
to make a starcraft movie I feel like
part of the issue with that is that it
would look very similar to starship
troopers which is based on a Robert
Highland book either way it's gonna be a
lot of fun and it's actually kind of
making me want to play the game again
I've taken like a break for the last
couple years from the game I played up
to the point where i got my 13 armor i
got my character like completely geared
out i'm normally i'm a tank but i do
have a couple DPS characters and then
real life came in and I started making
YouTube videos so as long as I've been
making YouTube videos I have not been
playing warcraft although I've just
started to play games again as you guys
have seen from my bad Arkham gameplay
everybody tell me their Warcraft stories
in the comments below everybody has a
warcraft story either they got in
trouble for playing it too much they had
a really awesome time or they had some
really special achievements it's such a
huge game that I feel like at least like
ninety percent of YouTube has played it
at some point just for reference the
movie's supposed to come out next summer
but they could always bump it around by
a couple weeks just just depending on
how things go with post-production so
I've got a couple other trailers from
comic-con that I'm working my way
through i'm going to do Star Wars next
be sure to subscribe to get that video
is anything from comic-con that I
haven't done yet that you guys want me
to do just let me know there is a new
Fantastic Four trailer too so if you
want me to do that just let me know in
the comments it's actually a pretty big
trailer so I might do that too but why
you guys wait for everything you can
click here for all my comic con trailer
videos I've done at least like three or
four at this point there's a lot of them
and you guys can click here for my
Deadpool trailer breakdown that was
probably the most popular footage that
was shown at Comic Con which i think is
kind of funny because it's actually a
pretty small movie compared to some of
the other ones but thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow